tengo un total tenemos 22 mil
pandilleros a los que los tenemos 58
nuestras durmiendo en el suelo
asignados con dos tiempos de comida y en
condiciones que estoy seguro que ninguno
de los pandilleros que están afuera
quieren ir al general y es importante
que sepan
es decir plantas de pasar de dios
vamos a bajar de dos tiempos a cero
tiempos de comidas y vamos a ver cuánto
tiempo
[Música]
por poco
sí
[Música]
dejamos de pagar la extorsión duda ahora
ya tenemos uno necesita ilustrar de
habla de poder hoy definitivamente no
estamos hablando nada los muchachos no
se han visto de bastante prácticamente
desaparecido y el comercio fluye la
gente
deja de tener miedo de venir al centro
caminar por las calles sin ningún
problema
[Aplausos]
bueno
[Música]
lastimosamente los bandos que llevaron a
que el presidente tomara esta decisión
fue la violencia fue mucha también mucha
muerte mucho muerte me gusta pero siguen
las injusticias que están agarrando a
personas que no tienen la suministro
nadie estaba narrando a personas que ya
han cumplido una condena ante quien en
su carta de libertad y no respetan y
éstos
[Música]